卒論が
ひとまず
完成した
いや
一応完成したんですけど
ここからなんですよ
担当の教授に見せたりね
顧問みたいな人に見せたりして
そこでしっかり修正して
ちゃんとね学校に提出して
初めて卒業論文が出来たって言えるので
まだ安心はできない
という複雑な動画
ぷぱぱっ
ぱっぱ
という複雑などうきょ
ゔゔぉー
という複雑な状況でちょっと質問コーナーいきます！
はい
今回はたくさんの応募ありがとうございました
今年一発目のちゃんとした動画なので
ちょっと適当に行くわ適当に
パパパっといきますよ
ではいこう！
ん゛ぶゔふん
イヒヒヒヒヒヒヒヒヒ
パッ
駄目だ、我慢できないから覚醒してくる
こりゃ駄目だ
とにかく全力で笑ってください
アハハハハハハハハ
アーハハハハハ
アアアアアアアア～
ウエッン
お豆腐早食い
ウエッ！！
はじめ、ショタはすきかい？
俺はショタだよ
ふーん
そうなのね
ねむい
寝よう
質問なんかない
ブッッ！
鼻に10円いくつ詰められるかやって
フッ！フーーーー！
血が出た！
最近さあー友達と同感と思ったことがあって
それがシュレック+鰹節＝はじめん
まじ共感だお
やめろ
真面目な質問です！二股してるわけではないんですが、今好きな人がいるのに元カレのことを忘れられません。
どーすればいいでしょうか。頼れるのははじめんしかいません。助けてください！！
難しい質問ですな！
どういう事なんだろう？
好きな人がいるのに、元カレのことが忘れられないって事は
事実上二人が好きって感じかな？
これはもう、どっちかをあきらめるしかありませんね
うーーーーーん難しいけども
付き合ったらいろいろモヤモヤしちゃうから
ひとまず、どっかのことを忘れラエロレロレロ（笑）
とりあえず、どっちかのことを忘れられるまでちょっと時間を置きましょう
待つのも大事です！
あっ、結構いいこと言ったよ今
はじめの母ちゃんでべそ！！
やめとけ殺されるぞ
俺の母さんに
洗濯機に入ってください
まじか
アアアアアアアア～
はじめしゃちょーがもし彼女と付き合っていたとして、ある日家に帰ったら彼女が知らない男とやっていた時の反応。
ただいま～
あっ！
あ～
うん
卒業論文消してみて
やめろ
冗談でもダメだ！
留年して欲しい
やめろ
授業とっててその授業の単位を取れないと僕は実は卒業できないので
その単位が取れていたかどうかは、動画に出します
お楽しみに！
絶対に7時に起きないといけないのに10時に起きたリアクションを体内のエネルギーを全て使い果たすくらい全力でやってください
ハッ！
アアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアア～
ドスコイドスコイダンスして
ドスコイ、ドスコイ、ドスコイパパパ
ドスコイ、パパパ
ドスドス、コイコイ、ドスコイコイダンス～
ぱっ、ぱぁぱらんぱ
なんてことをしてくれた
さあ、大根を瓦のごとく割るのだ
ハッ！
骨折れちゃった
僕のチャンネルを3秒で紹介！
りょうぺーチャンネルでは毎日うどんを食べる動画を
はじめんにずっと聞きたかったことがあるんだ
夜も眠れず、何日、いや、何年立ったことか
けど、この質問をすれば私達の仲もどう変わるのかを色々想像してしまうもんで、怖いんです。
でも知りたい！！っていう強い思いをこめて決めました。
今こそはじめんの答えを聞きたい。だから、ストレートに言っちゃいます。
はじめん、どんなに辛くても、正直に答えて下さい。
コーラとファンタどっちが好きですか？
コーラで
舌を鼻につけてください
ヴェェェ
あ、気持ち悪くなっちゃった
BIGチョコ？オレがもっとBIGにしてやるぜ！
なんか・・・
エロいね
µ'sのメンバーにしてください
どうぞ
自分の顔殴って「きもちぃー」っていってください。
うっ
きもちぃー
ふざけんなよ
はじめリバースリバースエボリューション
はじめ　リバースリバースエボリューーーション！
僕はある日こう思った。
ほんとに選ばれるのかと
親に相談したら　「あんた、はじめんが選んでくれるわけないでしょ
バカな事なんかしてないで勉強しなさいよ。返事は返事！上行きなさい！」と、。
バカな考えだって事は自分がよくわかってるんだよ、でも僕はやっぱ諦めることはできない。
だって、はじめんがﾁｭｷﾀﾞｶﾗ!!!!
ﾊｰｲｯ!!!!!!!!
元気でよろしい！
勉強する意味ってなんですか。
国語は日本語が喋れればいいし、数学は計算ができればいいし、理科は別に必要ないし、
社会はニュース見てればいいし、英語は日本にいたら使わなくていいですよね。
勉強に追われるのがわかりません。はじめしゃちょーはどう思いますか？
勉強する意味っていうのはですねー
まあ正直あまりないと思います
勉強すること自体に大きな意味はないかもしれませんが
しっかりこうね、取り組む姿勢っていうのが大事だと思います
しっかり勉強するっていうその頑張れる力が、
この先ね自分がしたいことが出てきた時の頑張る力になるんじゃないのかな
わかんないけどこつこつ頑張れる人って素敵だと思います
頑張ってね!
僕のも読んでる?
相談です......リアルに友達いません、どうしたらいいですか?
安心してくれぇ
俺もいないから
キス顔の自撮りを弟さんに送信!
ハッ
マジでいってんのかおれ
マジか
マージーか
あ送っちゃったよ
HIKAKIN親分とトロールを天秤にかけたとき、どっちを捨てますか?
バイチャー
全力で何かに成りきってから、倒れる
そして復活すると思いきや、しないでそのまま眠りにつく。。
その後はじめが起きることはなかった。
ナニコレつまんな
いやおい！
今回ちょっと急ぎ足でやっちゃったんですけども
まあ今回もね、たくさんのコメントありがとうございました。
というわけでまたいつか機会があればしようと思います
よかったらまたコメントお待ちしております
じゃあな！